Snoop dogs squashing his yearslong beef
with Donald Trump in the past the rap
star has been straight up nasty to the
former president and his supporters and
at one point Snoop pointed a fake gun at
a clown version of trump for one of his
music videos but snoop's now taking the
high road the rapper jumping on the
Trump train after the former president
tossed a pardon to one of the dog
father's friends saying quote I have
nothing but love and respect for Donald
Trump all right Jessica I see you ta
Swift and I raise you Snoop honestly I I
don't know what we're going to do when
Donald Trump wins the black vote because
of
this Greg what your thoughts on the
Snoop endorsement how significant is
this but I I do remember pointing a gun
at a clown version of you and then it
turned out it was you thank you the
point is not it's not that Trump is
gaining supporters it's that the Dems
are losing allies and ground all Trump
has to do is stay where he is and the
rest of America will catch up to him
suddenly the crash and arrogant American
Dad isn't so bad after all it also shows
you that a lot of politics is local and
decentralized it's defined best on how
it affects you personally so the issue
affects Snoop because it's personal and
IT addresses his own Safety and Security
so I think you're going to see this more
I think when especially when you look at
the migration issue blacks don't see
that politically perhaps as much as they
see it as a personal security and safety
issue
Snoop Dog yes with Biden at a 33%
approval rating it's no longer a
dangerous career move to say that your
friends and like Donald
Trump well okay I'm curious as to
whether or not Biden is told Snoop Dog
he ain't black yet all right and then I
also I want to for the record I want to
say that I was right about something
remember when Snoop Dog said when was it
in November he was giving up
smoke okay well he ended up partnering
with a smokeless brand it was all a
marketing stunt okay so there so there
Jessica do you have anything legitimate
to say well I'm glad that you recognize
that it's a totally illegitimate idea
that he's going to lose the black vote
um I think that you will start to see
it's kind of this anti-politician thing
that's happening where you just however
you're going to go in and do it in the
voting booth doesn't necessarily
translate to how you talk about things
and it does matter if someone helped
your friend out and one of the strongest
things Donald Trump did was bipartisan
Criminal Justice Reform and he got a lot
of good press from that a lot of
Democrats that were very supportive of
it and I include you in that as well I
yeah roll the tape I I thought it was
great it was bad
idea I take back everything I said oh so
funny hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now